yes lunchtime waits over that was easy
totally I feel like we just had her
snack an hour and 17 minutes ago I never
got into diets though I did take diet
pills in the 70s I loved these pills
they give me so much energy and I can
eat whatever I want
Oh Bob dad actually I was in a coma when
I woke up I had so much male weight loss
science has come a long way since then
ingredients carrot got a respect Paul
seems bad Jake why aren't you more upset
because Sofia's problem isn't with me
it's with her dumb boss that's something
I can fix
I'm gonna make him like me here is the
target geoffrey hoytsman now according
to the internet his interests are skiing
his Terrier Atlantic City the film 12
years of slave and nature obviously
nature is super boring and the slave
film is a little bit dicey it's real
dicey
yeah so I will focus mainly on skiing
and Atlantic City when I talked to him
tonight at the fundraiser for the
association of Brooklyn Public Defenders
aka the chamber of asses
oh wait that's too sexy the chamber of
snakes anyway it starts at 8:00 so you
should probably get dressed what I am
NOT going to that please Sarge just come
do it for me do it for love damn Jake
you know Terry loves love I mean all
right now put on your phoniest smile cuz
we're going into the belly of the beast
phonier phonier ah there it is into the
Beast
[Music]
sarch permission to arrest Hitchcock and
Scully
I've told you before it's not harassment
unless you can prove intent to fart no
it's not that they robbed me they ate my
Moose Tracks ice cream that's funny I
wouldn't think you like Moose Tracks my
boyfriend Marcus introduced me to it
what it is a delicious treat for all
ages Rosa okay look I think they've been
skimming people's desserts but weeks but
I could never prove did you see them
take ice cream no but Hitchcock has
fudge stains all over his chest
he's always got blood stains all over
his chest they'll deny everything we
need hard proof so let's get it step one
but a delicious pie in the fridge and
cover with poison that's step one step
two tell their widows there were thieves
it's go time sergeant hey Rosa I'm not
saying these are from your motorcycle
but I don't need ripped handlebars
outside you better not a mess with my
bike for this heist let me remind you
I'm carrying a weapon we all have to say
weapons damn Rosa where'd you get that
[Music]
the Scorpion has left the nest the Oscar
for best liar goes to you that's not an
Oscars category what's going on not to
be harsh Sarge but you're setting a
terrible example for your daughters and
they're gonna grow up to be total
failures you take that back no she's
right Jeff it's your children are doomed
where's the plaque over the last time I
don't know I've been working here the
whole time
ask them well actually we both fell
asleep and Jeffords never woke us up
coincidence
I don't need this you're not going
anywhere
sorry get away everyone get someone lock
the door oh of course it all makes sense
except for the parts I don't understand
to the fact that I still kind of think
Terry did this nope it was all me so we
don't know if anyone helped George Judy
escaped from this hospital security
cameras show him entering this courtyard
but never coming back out
dude just vanished Oh Terry hates
hospitals a week of death oh not you man
new week of life maybe you went up the
wall like this oh never mind
it's not possible sure
via Rosa how did you do that I'm a dark
past now you know my deepest shame go
well not at I saw you do it
I get how to do it too oh damn
you